so have you heard about the hottest new
mental disorder it's it's the it's the
newest one on the market you can go and
pick it up at Target or Walmart if you
want
it's called snapchat dysmorphia that's
the newest one we read a little bit from
the the story about it on The Daily wire
it says plastic surgeons say more people
are coming into their offices and asking
if the doctors can make them look like
they do in snapchat researchers from
Boston University School of Medicine's
Department of Dermatology wrote
previously patients would bring images
of celebrities to their consultations to
emulate their attractive features a new
phenomenon dubbed snapchat dysmorphia
has patients seeking out cosmetic
surgery to look like filtered versions
of themselves instead with fuller lips
bigger eyes or a thinner nose this is an
alarming trend because those filtered
selfies often present an unattainable
look and are blurring the lines of
reality and fantasy for these patients
okay so
people are going in and they're asking
for a plastic surgery so there were some
statistics about plastic surgery in this
article and trying to find them that
were pretty disturbing the Washington
reports that in Washington Post reports
that in a 20-17 survey the American
Academy of facial plastic and
reconstructive surgery found that 55% of
plastic surgeons said patients had
requested surgery to look better on
social media apps up 13% from the
previous year 55% over half of the
patients are going in and trying to
permanently alter their bodies
surgically just for the sake of social
media
now this really isn't that complicated
and it isn't this is not a mental
disorder eat either you see how easily
we come up with new mental disorders
just like that they just call it that
and it's snapchat dysmorphia and there
we go and now we've got a new mental
disorder on the books your if you're
wondering how we end up with 300 some
mental disorders in the diagnostic
Statistical Manual des Mental Disorders
this is how we end up with it because
it's just you can just make them up it's
just it's as easy as that if you if
you're a researcher writing a paper or
you're a doctor you just make up a new
one it's it's I mean it's kind of fun
actually you can just make up mental
sorters whenever you want but this is
not a mental disorder it's really if you
have any if we have any understanding of
the human condition it shouldn't be that
difficult to spot narcissism when we see
it this is just narcissism
these are narcissists who are who are
going to get plastic surgery mostly its
narcissists we get plastic surgery in
the first place
but especially when they're getting it
for the sake of social media they're
narcissists narcissism is when you take
an excessive interest in yourself
especially your appearance but not only
that I think we kind of had this have
this misguided idea of narcissism where
we think that you know a narcissist is
somebody who thinks too highly of
themselves who has a who has essentially
we conflate arrogance and narcissism and
then on the flip side we think that a
humble person is someone who thinks
lowly of himself someone who has a low
opinion of themselves but that's that's
not the case and that's why we would I
think we often assume that if somebody
is has a bad self-image and so they're
going to get plastic surgery well they
couldn't possibly be a narcissist
because they obviously think they have a
poor opinion of their own of their own
appearance but that's that that's just
not the way it works
a narcissism a narcissist is someone who
thinks about themselves too much
whether those are good or bad opinions
doesn't really matter the point is
they're spending way too much time
thinking about themselves whereas
someone who is humble is someone who
just doesn't think about themselves that
much
and when they do think about themselves
like a humble person in fact in order to
be humble you have to a part of humility
is recognizing your gifts and your
strengths and appreciating them and
being grateful for them but then not
dwelling on
so like a humble athlete is someone who
it's not that they don't realize they're
a good athlete no they know they're a
good athlete they just and they they
appreciate that fact within their just
go and they live their life they don't
think they're better than anyone because
of it they don't spend a lot of time
thinking about how great they are they
just they realize it they're grateful
and then they go on and they play the
game right so I think if you're if
you're obsessing all the time about your
physical flaws or what you perceive your
flaws to be then you're a narcissist and
your narcissist because there's a whole
world out there
and and there's their billions of people
none of them none of it has none of them
care about your physic flaws it's it
doesn't matter it's irrelevant to
everything yet all you can do is just
stare in the mirror and look at your
nose that you think is too big or
whatever
I think narcissism lies at the root of
many alleged mental disorders many
things that we consider mental disorders
are really at root just
narcissism just self obsession
and we we kind of create that in
ourselves because we spend way too much
time in our culture thinking about
ourselves we spend entirely too much
time looking inward into ourselves at
ourselves so we like to think that you
know in this culture we we have so much
anxiety we have so much stress we have
so much more of it than people in the
past must must must have had and we talk
as though we're the first generation to
ever have self-image issues or issues
with self-esteem or what have you but
none of that is new the reason why we
seem to have more of it is that we spend
so much time thinking about ourselves we
spend so much time analyzing our own
emotional state and when you do that
you're bound to find problems like when
you sit there and think how am I feeling
right now how do I feel about how I'm
feeling where are these feelings coming
from what do I look like how do I feel
about what I look like you know it's
just
i-i-i-i it's all about me and then when
you do that it's just inevitable that
there's gonna be anxiety there's gonna
be stress there's gonna be self-esteem
issues it's inevitable and I think we
could cure or treat or control at least
a lot of that if we just thought about
something else
this is why by the way I'm not a fan of
all of these love yourself campaigns and
you're beautiful just the way you are
and all that embrace your imperfections
all these marketing campaigns that it
seems like every you know cosmetic
company or or whatever any company that
sells toiletry items you know this is
this is this is what they do now this is
how they market but just which is
especially funny if a if a makeup
company markets itself that way embrace
yourself just the way you are but first
put on a little makeup okay but then
embrace yourself
I think those campaigns only contribute
to the problem because you're
encouraging people
yes you're encouraging people to think
positively about themselves instead of
negatively but really you should be
encouraging people to just stop thinking
about themselves it's it's not about
trying to shift your image of yourself
so that it's all positive it's just
about just it's just about getting away
from yourself not focusing on that
instead of focusing so much on loving
yourself focus on a good book
focus off put on some music focus on
that watch a documentary about about
dolphins okay
and focus on the dolphins just think
about the dolphins instead of yourself
for five seconds just think about
something else
focus on anything that isn't you I think
that's how to be a healthy person
if you ask a healthy per if you were if
you were to go up to a
mature and healthy person and ask them
do you love yourself how do you feel
about yourself do you love yourself I
think a healthy person would say sure I
guess they'd be kind of confused by the
question because they haven't really
thought about that they don't they don't
spend a lot of time thinking about how
they feel about themselves whereas if
you ask a narcissist an unhealthy person
if they love themselves they'll give you
a whole speech a whole monologue
explaining in detail exactly how they
see themselves how they feel about
themselves because that's all they ever
think about and this all relates of
course to to to people wanting plastic
surgery for snapchat because the same
thing happens with our physical
appearance if we spend all day staring
in mirrors or taking pictures of our own
faces inevitably we're going to notice
flaws because we all have them and then
we're gonna become obsessed with those
floors whereas if you aren't a
narcissist and you aren't so intently
focused on yourself you won't notice
your physical flaws as much and when you
do notice them you won't be as focused
on them or as obsessed with them because
you're just in general are not focused
on and obsessed with yourself it's it's
not hard to see how social media
especially something like snapchat
contributes to this
I don't think social media makes us
narcissists doesn't doesn't turn us into
narcissists exactly but it does it does
feed the narcissistic impulse because it
encourages us to think about ourselves
to think to think about our image
worst of all it encourages us to think
about our brand I got an email from a
guy a couple of days ago who said he
wanted some advice on how to build his
brand on social media the brand of
himself
which which is already an unhealthy way
of looking at yourself if you're say a
celebrity and you make money off of your
image to see yourself as a brand is
unhealthy although in that context
somewhat understandable but it's
completely it's a completely insane way
of looking at yourself if you're just a
normal person working a normal job and
now you're worried about your brand
right
and I know I'm not breaking any new
ground here
complaining about this but but have you
ever seriously stopped to think about
look let's just focus on on something
like something like snapchat or social
media what's what's like one of the
primary things people do is they they
they they take pictures of themselves of
their own faces and they post them
online right
but have you ever thought about the
whole concept of taking a selfie I mean
who would have ever predicted that one
day we'll have we'll have these these
high-powered cameras which we carry
around in our pockets and everybody
would have one but we would use them to
take pictures of our own faces six
hundred times a day where we're
experiencing life you know with our back
turn to it or even even if we want to
take a picture of something beyond
ourselves we have to take the picture so
that we're in it also you know so we're
taking the picture like where the thing
is behind us but we are also it because
we need ourselves I was at a lake
recently and you know there was just
this great view of the lake and there
were trees and there was the Sun was
poking through and there's a few clouds
in the sky they were bird she's a
beautiful view and there was a guy
standing not far for me he was trying to
get a picture of the lake but he had his
back turned to it because he was trying
to get the lake in the back right he
wanted the lake but he needed his his
own mug in the on the forefront of the
picture right
and it's like what why don't you just
get your face out of the way take a
picture of the lake I mean no one cares
what about your face but you know what
your face everyone knows what your face
looks like doesn't matter
so just take a picture or you know what
better yet don't don't take a picture of
the lake at all just experience it be in
the moment
sit there and look at the lake and think
wow that's beautiful
and experience the beauty don't don't
document it don't try to use it for
something just just be there
have it in your head something to think
about something to focus on that isn't
you and go about your day
kind of absorb this beautiful moment
into yourself
not into your phone but into yourself
and then carry it with you I think
that's probably a better even a better
strategy
but this is what social media has turned
us into it is an intensely self-centered
thing a thing that has you constantly
thinking about yourself and your in your
image and which causes you to see every
moment in your life as an opportunity to
get a great picture and post it so that
you could increase your brand awareness
it's very unhealthy and obviously it's
going to contribute to narcissism in a
very serious way
now I experienced this temptation all
the time I'll admit and it has an
increased intensity for me because this
is actually what I do for a living so I
make my living on the internet on social
media so III I have to be focused on it
so I always have that excuse for myself
that I can give myself but there's a
real there's a real danger
first of all like everyone else on the
internet there's a danger that I'm gonna
spend entirely too much time you know
thinking about myself
and this again has an added intensity
because so much of the email that I get
the messages that I get you know the
correspondence that that that I get
online I get a lot of it but but so much
of it is about me it's like people
emailing me to give me their opinions
about me and whether those are bad or
good opinions it's it's it's just not a
healthy thing to sit there and read
opinions about yourself it's not healthy
but the second danger is this I've
noticed that
every time I have a thought about
something every time I get lost in a
train of thought thinking about
something thinking about some issue some
idea whatever
very quickly I kind of interrupt my own
train of thought and I say to myself oh
this is good I need to use this I need
to use this for a video or a column or
my book or whatever and then I continue
in the thought
but now I'm thinking of how I'll phrase
it or how I'll write it or how I'm gonna
present it so it's not a it's not a real
thought it's not an organic real thought
anymore now it's like I'm constructing
something that I can then present to the
world and if I'm not careful to get to
the point where I I never have normal
human thoughts anymore
I'm always just writing articles in my
head or planning monologues or something
so sometimes I have to stop myself and I
have to say you know what no I'm just
gonna think about this thing I'm not
gonna use it I'm not gonna write it down
I'm not gonna say it into a camera I'm
not gonna publish it online I'm just
gonna think it this is my thought I'm
gonna keep it inside myself and I'm just
gonna have it there and that's all just
just like a she's like a reg like a
person I'm just going to be a person who
thinks things and and has them in his
head and that's all
in the same way I think we
we you know we should do that same thing
when it comes to taking pictures for
Instagram or snapchat or whatever this
is not a temptation that I have
personally with when it comes to taking
pictures because I hate cameras and I
hate taking pictures but people who are
inclined that way I think if you're in
that boat you should you should just
allow yourselves allow yourself
sometimes too simply experience a moment
to live in it to be there without
documenting it without trying to use it
for something without thinking oh this
is great for snapchat this is great for
Instagram is it's great for Facebook
just just just whatever even if you see
a beautiful view or you witnessed some
weird or funny scene out in public
whatever it is don't document it don't
use it don't don't don't bring it back
to yourself just be there
just live beer be a human
and have this moment and carry it with
you and don't tell anybody about it
that have a I guess what we would call
an internal life
and this is the thing I think I talk
about
talk about this a few months ago but
this is the the main thing that I think
social media and the Internet is robbing
us of it's robbing us of and it
certainly is doing it to me
it's robbing us of internal life
a life that we just have inside
ourselves that is not really about
ourselves about other things experiences
you know things we've seen ideas we've
had just that
where now we pour all of that out online
on social media
and we try to package it in a certain
way
in order to puff up our image to other
strangers who happen to be online
is it on a healthy thing and as I said
it is fuel for narcissism and
unfortunately all of us who are online
and on social media which I assume
everyone watching this or listening to
this right now is we all we there's just
a ton of fuel out there for four dinars
so there's a lot of narcissism fuel and
we have to avoid sometimes consuming it
I think
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed